let me live my best life let me be a
hero to myself
my goals for the second half of 2018
is to be my own personal hero
[Music]
social media people have you ever like
there's nothing i don't i don't know
where to begin with this if i see one
more
[ __ ] fat miserable loser
was wearing a t-shirt that has some sort
of self-help advice
to me like they've reached the mecca of
peace and happiness it's just like
is that [ __ ] t-shirt for you or is it
for me
you know i just saw this this [ __ ]
miserable looking person
sitting down in the airport you know
tens and tens and tens of [ __ ] pounds
overweight
eating [ __ ] food with a t-shirt that
says love yourself
you know what i mean and all of this
[ __ ] crap now where you pat people on
the back because they're [ __ ] up
their lives
but they still feel good about you know
what i like who i
am i'm not saying you shouldn't like who
you are but i mean you got to look at
yourself in the mirror at some point and
just be like dude the [ __ ] are we doing
here
you know not saying i'm perfect i'm not
a perfect person
[Applause]
right but i'm not you know sitting
around here like
calling myself a hero you know based off
of
all my [ __ ]
shortcomings
hollywood puts pressure yeah [ __ ] it
it's not a hollywood hollywood gives
people
what they want all right you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
so sick of everybody blaming this
innocent town
we here in hollywood happen to be some
of the
the most uh dependable
loyal honest human beings you're ever
going to meet i couldn't even get
through without laughing
whatever [ __ ] you this car this time
will give you whatever the [ __ ] you buy
okay and you've been looking at [ __ ]
abs and big tits
since the second they had moving
pictures so i i don't want to [ __ ]
hear it
these [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
then i like those other people the the
[ __ ] fat guys with the uh
with the tough guys [ __ ] on their shirt
you know
do i look like i give a [ __ ] you know
that's
no no you don't yeah i don't i i
i would believe that you don't give a
[ __ ] about anything
all right with your [ __ ] fungus
riddled toenails
while wearing your little [ __ ]
flip-flops
um here's one for the guys uh fat kid on
a bicycle
um i challenge you to watch this and not
[ __ ] laugh your balls off
and it's great if you just you know
what's great is after the kid falls off
if you look really closely it what
happens is when he goes flying over the
handlebars and his
[ __ ] meatball body lands
anybody's played sports has done this
you ever get tackled in football in your
arms underneath you and your
[ __ ] elbow basically goes into your
spleen
up under your liver and then [ __ ] you
know
smashes into your heart that's basically
what happens to this kid
and he makes he makes the greatest
he made you want to hear the noise tell
you what i'll play i'll play the audio
and i'm going to test your willpower
that if you can actually
hear the [ __ ] audio to this and not
watch it you're definitely you
you have you have some serious [ __ ]
willpower let me type this in real quick
fat there's a lot of audio on this one i
had my dog
fat kid wait a minute what the [ __ ] i
just messed that up
fat kid on a bicycle i'm sorry i can't
type with one hand
just bear with me children just bear
with me just
talk amongst yourselves do you ever have
that
when your teacher was going through a
divorce and she'd start breaking down
just talk amongst yourselves that kid on
a bicycle
bam i swear to god it's funny you're not
gonna be able to find now i have to
oh there it is fat kid on a bicycle i
got it
here we go listen to this audio all
right
here he comes here he comes here he
comes
oh it's the funniest [ __ ] thing ever
he's got big fat thighs he's got these
little booty shorts on
oh god that's a [ __ ] great one
there's nothing better that why is it so
funny to watch somebody get hurt
i don't know why um all right you guys
want to watch a [ __ ] up youtube video
um it's a fat guy
jumping into a frozen lake and uh
he goes right through the [ __ ] ice
and there's a moment there where i i i
don't know
i didn't really find it to be a funny
video and i thought his friends were
unbelievably ignorant um with their
incredible
uh lack of urgency with the situation
uh the situation i don't know how quick
hypothermia sets in
but uh i don't know judging by his
the [ __ ] weight of this guy and the
stress that's already putting on his
heart
the kid easily could have had a [ __ ]
heart attack and they were trying to
pull the [ __ ] out and
it's unreal he ends up walking out of
the lake like godzilla he's just got to
break the [ __ ] ice all the way back
to the shore
oh [ __ ] i'm sorry
that [ __ ] image just hit me ah
[Music]
alright
right
so anyways i gotta fly la to phoenix
phoenix to columbus all right
on u.s air so
i get on the plane and there's two empty
seats next to me
and it's getting close to the point
where they're going to close the door
to the plane and i'm excited like holy
[ __ ] i'm going to have this whole
[ __ ] road to myself
this will be nice i can stretch out a
little bit take my carry-on stick it
under the other chair this is going to
be great
right before they close the door lo and
behold this fat
tub of [ __ ] gets on the [ __ ] plane
all right and i'm thinking oh god
not me please for the love of god don't
pick my row
you know when you do that [ __ ] you're
just [ __ ] willing the guy to sit down
as he waddles his fat ass down the
[ __ ] aisle
it's him and his [ __ ] lady right
so he [ __ ] comes all the way up comes
to my row and he's just standing there
and i'm hoping he's just standing there
because he's putting his stuff in the
overhead compartment i can literally
feel
the [ __ ] heat radiating off of his
body
from the 22 years of mistakes that he's
put in his goddamn stomach
all right and what does he do oh yeah
i'm in that bro
i mean your rose so i gotta get up and
what does he do his feet lets his
[ __ ] girl
sit by the window and then he sits in
the middle seat
and this fat [ __ ] tub of [ __ ] [ __ ]
this dude was so fat i was sitting
behind his back fat
you know what i mean he was like fat and
round
it was like sitting next to a planet
with a head
you know it was like you could the
roundness of this guy
okay so he's trying to be less fat god
bless him
so he crosses his arms when all it does
is just causes
fat lat to [ __ ] bulge out even more
into my airspace that i [ __ ] paid for
and it's not real all i'm thinking is
why the [ __ ] did he take the window seat
and then post up against his girlfriend
my shoulder was getting hot
from his arm it was he was on me this
[ __ ] guy was on me
if i was claustrophobic they would have
had to turn the plane around this is how
much this guy was in my chair
and i'm thinking why the hell why didn't
you just take the [ __ ] window seat
you fat
[ __ ] have a little bit of [ __ ]
consideration your tub of [ __ ]
you know with your basketball shorts
like you actually never played a goddamn
day in your life his [ __ ] legs spread
out like he was gonna give birth to a
baby calf
you know
why don't you sit near the window you
know what i realized after a while he
didn't sit near the window because he's
so
[ __ ] fat he can't
he can't if he sat by the window his
other fat lat would have blown out the
window we all would have got sucked out
unless his tub of [ __ ] body [ __ ]
somehow got stuck in the fuselage
which if you sum
wouldn't be beyond you a possibility
unfucking believable and he's sitting
there this is what kills me
he's sitting there and he's he's biting
his nails and i just want to be like
dude
do you ever stop eating is there a
moment and you're literally consuming
yourself right now
i know i know i know what you guys think
well hey bill why don't you fly first
class
oh yeah well hey why don't you go [ __ ]
yourself
hypothetical person who said that
okay i understand i bought a coach seat
i know what that means that means
my [ __ ] knees are gonna be in my
chest that means
if i'm even slightly leaned forward and
the guy in front of me reclines he's
going to hit me in the head i understand
that
okay i get it but that doesn't mean
that this tub is [ __ ] i shouldn't have
to pay an extra couple of [ __ ] grand
uh or whatever 1500 bucks
so somebody else's lard isn't in my lap
i am full on 100 behind
you having to buy two seats when you're
on an airplane okay
i'm sorry you're fat okay
but you made your choices this is one of
the things
this is a good thing you got to buy two
seats you got less money for cookies
maybe that'll be a goal maybe that'll be
your bottoming out but
it's it's absolutely ridiculous
that i have to i'm literally leaning out
into the [ __ ]
aisle my giant microwave oven head
is out there and then i got to deal with
the stewardess going excuse me sir
excuse me sir can you not steer in this
here please sir
all right i gotta watch if i can't start
yelling here i'm in a hotel room again
i already got one strike against me they
probably build a [ __ ]
file on me um yeah i'm leaning out there
that was this is the best part the food
cart comes
okay they asked me what do i you know
they asked the dude what he wants to
drink he goes can i have a coke
can i have a coke i just want to be a
dude how about a water
how about a salad are you trying to make
yourself even fatter during the flight
you know what that soda is going to do
to your already distended [ __ ] belly
you already can't even put the [ __ ]
tray down
this dude couldn't put the tray down he
tried
he tried to put the train oh my god this
[ __ ] guy i swear to god
the thoughts i was thinking it was
embarrassing
i was sitting there thinking like you
know i'm so glad this dude's gonna die
young
can you believe that i'm not happy in
real life that that's gonna happen
but that's how [ __ ] uncomfortable i
was and that's how [ __ ] mad i was at
this guy
absolutely you gotta buy two seats
people you gotta do it
i love when they try to leave the
[ __ ] arm up too i don't play that i
[ __ ] shave that ham
right down i bring the [ __ ] dick
right the [ __ ] down
[ __ ] sit here making me uncomfortable
and you you want to relax
if i could i put my foot in your chest
to make your belt even tighter that's
what i do to you cut off your
circulation to your legs maybe you'd get
up and take a walk
there's no excuse for it
you know and i know this is probably
coming off insensitive you know
something i've been a redhead my whole
life nobody gives a [ __ ]
we don't get we don't we're not
considered handicapped
capped we're not considered handicapped
this always happens when i scream all
weekend
we're not considered handicapped we
don't get our own parking spaces these
tubs of [ __ ]
they're getting their own parking spaces
now making a shorter walk to the store
making them even fatter